the Japanese say Tokyo 2020 is in the
lap of the Shinto gods but it's this man
that Thomas back the old powerful
president of the International Olympic
Committee who will have the final say
for now he says it's on following a very
comprehensive discussion today in the
executive port the IOC remains fully
committed to the success of the Olympic
Games at Tokyo 2020 I would like to
encourage all the athletes to continue
their preparation for the Olympic Games
Tokyo 2020 with the great confidence and
with full steam with back shaking
questions it was up to his
communications man to tackle the
skeptics as you know there's not even an
international travel ban and still not a
pandemic announced all the advice we're
getting is that the games can and will
go ahead there are some issues and
complications with with qualification
although thankfully national Impa
committees and if's are working very
closely together and we seem so far to
be doing a very good job of making sure
a fleets can compete so at this precise
time we are working moving ahead and
expecting the games to begin on the 24th
of July the Olympics is a nine a billion
pound event in seven years in the
planning it's no surprise the IOC should
seek to keep the show on the road
but in Japan they're already looking at
plan B and whether their contract means
it could be held later in the year
it only says if the games are not to be
held within 2020 it depends on how this
is interpreted but it can be read as
allowing a postponement within 2020 this
clock is ticking down as the Tokyo
Olympics grows ever nearer it's now just
a hundred and forty-two days to go but
who knows if we'll actually have a Tokyo
Olympics at all and if we do what would
it look like who will be there and when
will it happen with the IOC refusing to
offer reassurances to fans with tickets
or big-money sponsors so far we still
don't know despite mr. Beck's pleading
where this ship is heading Martha
Kellner Sky News listen